[Musique]
Chanel n'est pas une fragrance qui vous
fait tourner la tête il s'agit bien la
photographie
il a parcouru le monde pendant 7 ans
avant d'être photographe ici à chinois
il a été agent de méthode décorateur
d'intérieur et même directeur commercial
[Musique]
ça va Camille merci pour les pompes mon
légionnaire je t'en prie voilà mon
channel on est où ici là on est à
chinois dans la ville où j'ai décidé de
m'installer après avoir parcouru le
monde avoir mille et une aventures nous
sommes chez des amis dans une demeure
absolument exceptionnelle comme tu peux
le constater mais pourquoi sinon parce
que tu aurais pu aller ailleurs ah mais
j'ai grandi ici moi je vais arriver tout
petit à Chinon j'ai fait mes études ici
en Indre-et-Loire mais alors Chanel
comment tu es venu à la photo on m'a
prêté un appareil photo je suis à
l'avenir et à l'origine c'était pour
ramener des vues afin des dessiner car
je suis d'abord un dessinateur et un
peintre enfin j'espère on va voir tout
ça ou pas
[Musique]
en fait c'est comme la tarte tatin ça
vient d'une erreur mon appareil était
réglé pour faire 5 photos d'affilée avec
5 expositions différentes afin de les
assembler et d'avoir une bonne dynamique
et quand j'ai mis mon appareil photo et
que j'appuyé et je me suis dit ah non
pas bon réglage donc j'ai fait ce
mouvement sauf qu'en faisant ça 1 2 3 4
5 arrivé à la maison ça a donné quelque
chose de bizarre j'ai amélioré le
système par rapport au réglages et c'est
une photo qui est faite en se déplaçant
voilà donc ça fait des superpositions
alors là aussi on a figé le mouvement je
trouvais quand même plutôt pas mal et
c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé cette
série mouvement c'est-à-dire de figer un
mouvement mais le mouvement a toujours
fait partie de ta vie tu as toujours été
en mouvement tu as été légionnaire mais
parajustice effectivement je me suis
engagé à la Légion étrangère les
parachutistes en Corse ou j'ai à peu
près sauté en marche de tout ce qui
roule qui coule qui vole et qui vole pas
ce que tu veux on va parler de chinois
un peu c'est quand même ton endroit de
prédilection tu as sorti des livres sur
Chinon quel est ton spot préféré il y a
plein de jolis points de vue ici mais
quand même il y a sur les bords de
Vienne une plage tu vas voir la vue tu
as coupé le souffle alors direction la
plage d'ailleurs
50 pompes
[Musique]
quelle vue quel spot mon pote c'est
vraiment ton pop préféré quoi tous les
soirs on a un ciel qui change un vrai
tableau commence tout ça ça t'inspire
pour tes photos la réponse est dans la
question c'est à dire que on a cette
forteresse c'est quand même pas banal
chaque jour est un tableau là on discute
ensemble mais là je vois une photo il y
a des perspectives il y a des lignes il
y a des coupes entre toi et chinois
c'est une véritable histoire d'amour
quoi c'est mon ADN c'est chez moi ça a
toujours été chez moi merci de m'avoir
fait découvrir cette plage par ce beau
temps ce soleil Chanel
il avait le soleil sur son front et dans
ses yeux de la Ligue 1
bon comme d'habitude Kamini
[Musique]
c'est chaud la photo